wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
guten abend was kann ich für sie tun
haben sie noch ein zimmer frei nehmen
sie das zimmer für eine nacht oder für
mehrere nächte das noch mal für eine
nacht vielleicht bleibe ich länger ich
nehme an dass sie ein einzelzimmer
möchten ist das richtig ja bitte ein
einzelzimmer
möchten sie das zimmer mit oder ohne
frühstück das frühstück ist nicht im
preis inbegriffen
ohne frühstück bitte dann benötige ich
noch ihren ausweis oder reisepass das
zimmer ist in der vierten etage
das macht dann 139 euro für eine
übernachtung ohne frühstück sansibar
oder mit kreditkarte
entschuldigen sie aber ihre karte wird
nicht akzeptiert
danke
entschuldigen sie die umstände wie
gesagt ihr zimmer ist in der vierten
etage den aufzug finden sie von rechts
ich wünsche ihnen einen angenehmen
aufenthalt
danke ich mir auch